a pris un bus à Delhi avec un ami.
Il y avait six hommes dans ce bus,
de jeunes hommes que vos pourriez rencontrer tous les jours en Inde,
et le récit de ce qui a suivi, à vous faire froid dans le dos,
les médias indiens et internationaux en ont fait l'étalage encore et encore.
Cette fille a été violée à répétition,
pénétrée de force avec une tige émoussée,
battue, mordue, et laissée pour morte.
Son ami a été bâillonné, attaqué, et assommé.
Elle est morte le 29 décembre.
Et à un moment où la plupart d'entre nous
se préparaient pour accueillir la nouvelle année,
l'Inde a plongé dans l'obscurité.
Pour la première fois de l'histoire,
les hommes et femmes dans les villes d'Inde
ont ouvert les yeux sur l'horrible vérité de la condition de la femme dans le pays.
Comme beaucoup d'autres jeunes femmes,
j'étais absolument terrifiée.
Je ne pouvais pas croire que quelque chose de pareil
puisse arriver dans une capitale nationale.
J'étais en colère et frustrée,
mais surtout, je me sentais complètement impuissante.
Mais, qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ?
Certains écrivent des blogs, d'autres l'ignorent,
d'autres encore protestent.
J'ai tout fait.
En fait, c'est ce que tout le monde faisait il y a deux ans.
Les médias étaient plein d'histoires
de toutes les choses horribles
que les hommes indiens étaient capables de faire.
Ils étaient comparés à des animaux, des bêtes sexuellement réprimées.
En fait, cet évènement était tellement étranger et impensable
dans la tête d'un Indien,
que la réponse des médias indiens,
du public et des politiques a prouvé une chose :
personne ne savait quoi faire.
Et personne ne voulait être responsable de cela.
En fait, voici quelques commentaires indélicats
proférés dans les médias par des gens importants
en réponse à la violence sexuelle envers les femmes en général.
Le premier est fait par un membre du parlement,
le second par un leader spirituel,
et le troisième par l'avocat de la défense
quand la fille se battait pour sa vie et qu'elle est décédée.
En tant que femme, suivant cela jour après jour,
j'étais fatiguée.
Alors en tant qu'écrivain et activiste pour l'égalité des sexes,
j'ai beaucoup écrit sur les femmes,
mais cette fois-ci, j'ai réalisé que c'était différent,
parce qu'une partie de moi s'est rendue compte
que j'étais aussi en partie cette jeune femme,
et j'ai décidé que je voulais changer cela.
J'ai fait quelque chose de spontané, hâtif.
Je me suis connectée sur une plate-forme citoyenne de journalisme
du nom d'iReport,
et j'ai enregistré une vidéo parlant de ce à quoi ça ressemblait à Bangalore.
J'ai parlé de ce que je ressentais, j'ai parlé des réalités fondamentales,
et j'ai parlé des frustrations de la vie en Inde.
En quelques heures, le blog était largement diffusé,
et des commentaires et pensées sont arrivés de partout dans le monde.
À ce moment, j'ai compris plusieurs choses.
La première est que la technologie était toujours à portée
pour beaucoup de jeunes femmes comme moi.
La deuxième est que, comme moi, la plupart des jeunes femmes
s'en servent très peu pour exprimer leur point de vue.
La troisième est que j'ai réalisé pour la première fois
que ma voix comptait.
Dans les mois qui ont suivi,
j'ai couvert une série d'évènements à Bangalore
qui n'avaient pas leur place dans l'actualité principale.
Dans le parc de Cubbon, qui est un grand parc à Bangalore,
nous nous sommes réunis avec plus de 100 autres personnes
alors que des groupes de jeunes hommes s'avançaient en portant des jupes
pour prouver que les habits ne sont pas une invitation au viol.
Quand j'ai fait un reportage sur ces évènements,
j'avais l'impression d'avoir une charge,
une voie pour libérer toutes les émotions que j'avais en moi.
Je suis allée à la marche de l'hôtel de ville,
où les étudiants brandissaient des pancartes disant :
« Tuez-les, pendez-les. »
« Vous ne feriez pas ça à votre mère ou vos sœurs. »
Je suis allée à une veillée à la bougie où les citoyens se sont réunis
pour parler ouvertement du problème des violences sexuelles,
et j'ai enregistré beaucoup de billets
en réponse à l'inquiétude que créait la situation
à ce moment-là en Inde.
Leurs réactions m'ont embrouillée.
Alors que des commentaires de soutien arrivaient de partout dans le monde,
il y en avait aussi des vicieux.
Certains m'ont traitée d'hypocrite.
Certains m'ont traitée de victime, d'apologiste du viol.
Certains ont même dit que j'avais des motivations politiques.
Mais ce commentaire décrit plutôt bien ce dont nous parlons aujourd'hui.
Mais j'allais bientôt apprendre que ce n'était pas tout.
Aussi responsabilisée que je me sentais avec cette nouvelle liberté
que cette chaîne de journalisme citoyen me donnait,
je me retrouvais dans une situation inconnue.
À un moment, en août dernier, je me suis connectée à Facebook
et je regardais mes actualités,
et j'ai remarqué qu'il y avait un lien que mes amis avaient partagé.
J'ai cliqué sur le lien,
et il m'a amenée à un reportage mis en ligne par une fille américaine
du nom de Michaela Cross.
Le reportage s'appelait :
« Inde : l'histoire que vous ne vouliez jamais entendre. »
Et dans ce reportage, elle racontait son récit de première-main
de confrontation à l'agression sexuelle en Inde.
Elle a écrit : « Il n'y a aucune façon de se préparer aux yeux,
les yeux qui chaque jour fixaient mon corps avec tant de droit,
sans changement d'expression que je croise leur regard ou non.
Allant chez l'épicier ou le tailleur,
je recevais des regards si aiguisés
qu'ils me découpaient, morceau par morceau. »
Elle a appelé l'Inde, paradis des voyageurs et enfer des femmes.
Elle disait qu'elle était suivie, pelotée et qu'on se masturbait devant elle.
Plus tard dans la soirée, ce reportage s'est propagé.
Il était sur des chaînes d'information partout dans le monde.
Tout le monde en parlait.
Il avait plus d'un million de vues,
un millier de commentaires et de partages,
et je me suis trouvée témoin d'une chose très similaire.
Les médias étaient pris dans ce cercle vicieux
de l'opinion et d'explosion
et sans issue.
Alors ce soir-là, alors que je me demandais
comment je devais répondre,
je me suis trouvée pleine de doutes.
Vous voyez, en tant qu'écrivain,
je parlais du problème en tant qu'observatrice,
en tant qu'Indienne, je me sentais embarrassée et incrédule,
et en tant qu'activiste, je regardais cela en tant que défenseur des droits,
mais en tant que journaliste citoyenne,
je me sentais soudainement très vulnérable.
Je veux dire, la voilà, une jeune femme
qui utilisait une chaîne pour parler de son expérience comme je le faisais,
et pourtant je me sentais troublée.
Personne ne vous dit jamais que la vraie responsabilisation
vient en vous donnant la permission de penser et d'agir.
La responsabilisation est souvent perçue comme un idéal, une issue merveilleuse.
Quand nous parlons de responsabilisation,
nous parlons souvent de donner aux gens l'accès au matériel,
l'accès aux outils.
Mais la responsabilisation est une émotion.
C'est un sentiment.
Le premier pas vers la responsabilisation,
est de vous donner l'autorité,
la clé de la volonté indépendante,
et pour les femmes partout,
peu importe qui nous sommes ou d'où nous venons,
c'est l'étape la plus difficile.
Nous avons peur du son de notre propre voix
car il est un aveu,
mais c'est ce qui nous donne le pouvoir de changer notre environnement.
Dans cette situation où j'étais confrontée à tellement de types de réalités,
je n'étais pas sûre de comment juger,
parce que je ne savais pas ce que cela signifierait pour moi.
J'avais peur de juger, parce que je ne savais ce que cela ferait
si je ne soutenais pas le même point de vue que cette fille.
Je ne savais pas ce que cela signifierait pour moi
si je défiais la vérité de quelqu'un d'autre.
Mais pourtant c'était simple.
Je devais prendre une décision :
devrais-je parler ou rester silencieuse ?
Après y avoir beaucoup pensé,
j'ai enregistré une vidéo en réponse,
et j'ai dit à Michaela que l'Inde a différentes facettes,
et j'ai aussi essayé d'expliquer
que les choses allaient aller
et j'ai exprimé mes regrets quant à ce à quoi elle avait été confrontée.
Et quelques jours après,
j'ai été invitée à parler avec elle en direct,
et pour la première fois j'ai tendu la main à cette fille
que je n'avais jamais rencontrée, qui était si loin,
mais de qui je me sentais si proche.
Depuis que ce reportage a été porté au grand jour,
plus de jeunes gens que jamais
parlaient d'agression sexuelle sur le campus,
et l'université à laquelle Michaela appartenait,
lui a donné l'aide dont elle avait besoin.
L'université a même pris des mesures
pour entraîner ses élèves à se parer des compétences dont elles ont besoin
pour faire face à des défis comme les agressions.
Et pour la première fois, j'ai senti que je n'étais pas seule.
S'il y a une chose que j'ai apprise en tant que journaliste citoyenne active
au cours des dernières années,
c'est notre terrible manquement en tant que société
à trouver activement des voies sur lesquelles nous pouvons être entendus.
Nous ne nous en rendons pas compte que lorsque nous défendons nos droits,
nous ne le faisons pas uniquement en tant qu'individus,
nous le faisons pour nos communautés,
nos amis, nos pairs.
La plupart d'entre nous disons que les droits des femmes sont reniés,
mais la vérité est souvent que les femmes se refusent ces droits.
Dans un sondage récent en Inde,
95 % des femmes qui travaillent dans les technologies de l'information,
l'aviation, le milieu hospitalier et les centres d'appels,
ont dit ne pas se sentir en sécurité à rentrer seule
tard dans l'après-midi ou la soirée après leur travail.
Au Bangalore, d'où je viens,
ce nombre est de 85 %.
Dans les zones rurales d'Inde,
si quoi que ce soit doit se passer après les récents viols en gang à Badaun
et les attaques à l'acide à Odisha et Aligarh qui sont censés passer,
nous devons agir très prochainement.
Ne vous méprenez pas,
les défis auxquels les femmes vont être confrontées
en racontant leurs histoires sont réels,
mais nous devons commencer à poursuivre
et essayer d'identifier des moyens de participer à notre système
et pas juste de poursuivre aveuglément les médias.
Aujourd'hui, plus de femmes que jamais
défendent leurs droits et interrogent le gouvernement indien,
et c'est le résultat de ce courage.
Il y a six fois plus de femmes qui déclarent des agressions,
et le gouvernement a passé la Loi (Amendement) Criminelle, en 2013,
pour protéger les femmes des attaques sexuelles.
Pour finir ce discours,
j'aimerais juste dire
que je sais que beaucoup d'entre nous dans cette pièce avons nos secrets,
mais parlons-en.
Combattons la honte et parlons-en.
Cela pourrait être une plate-forme, une communauté,
les êtres qui vous sont chers, peu importe qui ou comment,
mais parlons-en.
La vérité est que la fin de ce problème
commence avec nous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)